nous avons échangé longuement avec la
famille du principal suspect celui qui
est soupçonné bien d'avoir tiré sur le
policier c'est une famille abattue que
nous avons rencontré d'abord une
discussion avec l'oncle et la tante
ils décrivent leurs neveux comme un
petit délinquant et bien qu'ils avaient
de mauvaises fréquentations au sein du
quartier mais qui n'aurait rien à voir
selon lui avec le profil d'un meurtrier
et ensuite eh bien c'est la mère de ce
principal suspect qui est venu à notre
rencontre c'est une mère qui est
extrêmement investi selon elle dans
l'éducation de ses enfants mais qu'ils
n'avaient pas les moyens financiers pour
subvenir à leurs à leurs besoins alors
est-ce que bfm tv a bien fait de
diffuser le portrait tu du présumé
voilà juste parlé jeudi auprès du maire
parce que le suspect nie toujours les
faits oui selon lui au führer et vous
vous dites non maintenant on a encore la
preuve que la justice se fait totalement
en direct et dans les médias maintenant
avant se demander si on pouvait diffuser
la photo des coupables d notamment des
terroristes at on se demande si on doit
diffuser la photo des suspects ce jeune
homme vous l'avez dit il nie
complètement donc imaginer qu'il soit
coupable
le préjudice pour lui il ya même des
gens qui l'ont reconnu l'entrée de la
baie il nous en parle
il est important à la photo était
évidemment sur bfm ça a été diffusé on a
vu son visage quasiment ya des gens qui
l'ont reconnu qu'ils ont identifiées
donc imaginer le président le préjudice
pour lui s'il est innocent c'est
terrible alors gilles verdez vous dites
oui vous absolument
c'est un énorme scoop journalistique moi
quand j'étais à la tête du parisien je
l'aurais diffusé ya pas d'aveu mais ya
quand même des témoignages à charge et
en plus bfm a parfaitement respecté le
contradictoire il ya la famille et à la
version le fait comme vous le disiez
cyril qu'il dément qu'il conteste
donc je pense que cet équilibre et c'est
un tel document avec une telle force que
je leur dis bravo
estelle pour le faire simplement parce
que le collègues du policier d'éric
masson a vu la scène lui même a été à
juste qui s'est passé il a fait ce soir
une balle donc déjà il a vu de ses
propres yeux le jeune cet appel ayoub
qui est un collègue aussi du génie
laisse à confirmer donc je ne vois pas
du moins qu'il ya des personnes qui ont
confirmé que c'était vrai pourquoi ne
pourrais pas le montrer il ya qu un père
de famille qui est mort il ya une femme
tu te retrouve veuve des enfants qui se
retrouvent seules ces familles qui est
détruite c'est pour protéger nos
citoyens français donc du moins qu'il ya
des personnes qui ont vu la scène je ne
vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait pas le
mettre alors tous à l'arrivée des boues
dit non quand on est journaliste
je suis pas d'accord avec toi j la
partie moment où on donne une
information et supplémentaires il faut
qu'elle ait un sens et quelque chose
cette information supplémentaire
en quoi cette information supplémentaire
c'est-à-dire cette photo apporte quelque
chose de plus à l'information on sait
que c'est un jeune homme qu'il a 19 ans
et qu'il pour l'instant nie être
l'auteur des faits donc en quoi cette
photo là apporte un plus pour le
téléspectateur rien la faute aux alpes
elle pourrait éventuellement être
intéressante appartement où l'anc est
allé close et où on dit c'est lui et on
est au procès avant elle n'a pas
d'intérêt puisqu'on a déjà l'info un
jeune de 19 ans qui pour l'instant est
le suspect et qui nie les faits nicolas
mais moi ce qui me choque c'est le
déroulement de la faire c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de dire
qu'il est qu'il est coupable
vous avez la soeur qui commence à parler
et qui entend puisqu'on en donne de plus
en plus d'informations c'est à dire que
après on va chercher la soeur qui dit
qu'elle était avec lui à ce moment là
donc qui ne peut pas être coupable mais
en train de faire la faire à la place de
la police ce qui mettrait en concurrence
contre la presse il ya quelques jours
il ya deux jours il dénoncer tous les
médias qui relayait photo identité des
suspects qui selon lui ralentissent
l'enquète ils sont encore exprimés
aujourd'hui le procureur à ce midi sur
cette affaire selon lui le suspect nie
toujours les faits comme vous voulez dis
donc c'est vrai que l'affairé et on a
quand même l'expérience on a lu comme
une expérience qui a été terrible et
douloureuse qui a une paire cacher ou
joural elle est quand même que les
tueurs suivait en direct la faire sur
bfm
mais on va pas recommencer une deuxième
fois là aujourd'hui pour l'instant il
est présumé coupable
login mais pas coupable il est présumé
innocent par benjamin benjamin lucas
ouais moi je suis frais quand j'entends
madame dire
voilà il faut le faire à la télé la
justice ne se rend pas en prime time
on forme des policiers des magistrats
des avocats tout un monde du droit qui a
la responsabilité
quand les lois sont transgressées de
mener les enquêtes de défendre ceux qui
sont accusés et je vous ai laissé je
vais vous exposer et de condamner quand
ils doivent l'être
les auteurs d'actes d'actes criminels et
horrible comme comme celui qu'elle nous
avons nous avons assisté
je crois qu'on peut pas se passer de la
justice dans une république et je crois
qu'on ne peut pas considérer que la
justice se rend à la télévision par
ailleurs écoutons ce que nous disent les
professionnels du droit sur cette
affaire ils nous disent que diffuser la
photo d'un suspect peut nuire à lenquête
peut nuire à l'interpellation de ce
suspect alors et ça c'était un jeu et je
termine d'un mot je crois que les médias
comme les responsables politiques ont
une grande responsabilité nous vivons
dans une période dans laquelle il ya de
la violence c'est pas propre à cette
époque là il y en a toujours eu la
violence dans nos sociétés simplement
maintenant elle est médiatisée plus vite
et elle se diffuse plus vite est-ce que
nous rajoutons nous superposant à cette
violence une violence supplémentaire une
tension supplémentaire dans le débat
politique dans le débat démocratique
ou est ce que nous essayons de remettre
de la raison et de permettre à la
justice de faire son travail moi je
souhaite que la justice puisse faire son
travail et la justice d'ailleurs rend
des décisions au nom du peuple français
c'est beaucoup mieux que le faire en
version télé réalité 2 minutes parce que
je vais avoir l'avis de l'accord de
l'avocat avi bitton au niveau de la
justice
est-ce que ça va ralentir l'enquète non
réponse est non mais ce qui nous
départager en réalité dans ce débat
c'est la loi et si le tribunal
et je pense que si cette affaire
aller en justice il y aurait des chances
que le tribunal condamne bfm pourquoi
parce que nous avons tous que nous
soyons criminel ou pas nous avons tous
un droit à l'image personne ne peut
diffuser notre image 160g heureusement
il y a effectivement une exception que
les tribunaux admettent c'est lorsque la
l'image a un intérêt à la légitime pour
l'information du public
par exemple si cette personne était
encore recherchée et compte diffuser son
image pour pouvoir l'interpeller
parce qu'elle est dangereuse ça aurait
un intérêt légitime mais là en
l'occurrence cette personne elle
a été interpellée elle est entre les
mains de la justice quel intérêt
légitime qu'est ce que ça nous apporte
d'avoir sa photographie et je rappelle
autre chose il y à un article dans la
loi sur la presse qui prévoit une peine
de quinze mille euros d'amendé pour
quiconque diffuse l'image d'une personne
menottée
alors qu'elle n'a pas encore été
condamnés souvenons nous par exemple de
la sphère dominique strauss kahn
ouais où on voyait son image sur les
chaînes de télévision évidemment il
n'était pas dans une position où on
était porté plainte
menotté il aurait pu porter plainte et
faire condamner les chaînes de
télévision quinze mille euros d'amande
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans cette
affaire parce qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de présomption d'innocence
rappelons le dans cette affaire la
plainte de la partie civile de la
plaignante a été classée sans suite et
dominique strauss kahn n'a pas été jugé
seul dans cette affaire mais au-delà de
l'aspect juridique moi je trouve que
tout l'aspect moral on a décidé de ne
plus diffuser la tête des terroristes
parce que ce sont des monstres et qu'on
n'a pas envie de les mettre en héros et
comme danser ça certains endroits
j'appelle pas ça des jeunes mais ces
délinquants et ont déjà la haine du flic
donc montrer le visage de cette personne
c'est trop d'honneur à lui faire et
j'estime que justement on n'avait pas à
le montrer parce que c'est pas un héros
d'avoir tué un fric et personne n'a
besoin de voir ce visage je suis
d'accord avait quasiment personne sur ce
plateau tout simplement parce que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on couvre
toujours les délinquants pourquoi on
devrait faire des pincettes avec eux
pourquoi ne peut pas montrer leur visage
il a des personnes qui l'ont du même son
collègue aliou bah j'avais 11 ans l'a vu
à confirmer tout droit pourquoi ne pas
le montrer par vous avez raison madame
combien d'années d'études de droit de
formation bénéficier pour dire
aujourd'hui que vous allez rendre la
justice sur un plateau
metrolinx si je ne vous permets pas un
policier qui nous a fermé sa madame
madame énormément je ne vous permet pas
de dire que réussie des gens qui
seraient complaisant avec des auteurs
d'actes aussi atroces que celui-ci oui
il ya pas vrai oui non madame sinon ce
n'est pas vrai moi je suis jamais venu
dans l'île puisque vous d'ailleurs moi
je n'agis pas comme un retour comme vous
le faites avec 100 watts à chaque fois
qu'une affaire comme celle-ci d'accord
je n'agis pas comme un vautour qui va
sur des corps encore chaud les prendre
dans le bec pour aller les agissez sur
les plateaux de télévision tbs mois la
république la règle et le terrain claude
la république c'est la musique il y en a
qui sont plus que cela juste alerter la
justice doit elle doit d'être désiré
vous êtes un jet de la justice elle doit
agir avec sérénité c'est la condition
pour que la justice soit respectée
puisque ya rien qui va je suis ravi de
voir que vous indique si rimouski
parce que vous faites quelques vidéos et
que vous diffusez les théories de
l'extrême droite à longueur de journée
vous êtes plus habilité qu'un magistrat
qu'un policier qu'un avocat a traité des
fissures et juste qu'un journaliste
sérieux chasse au pelage aura les cimes
les victimes elles attendent elles
souffrent c'est toujours les personnes
les bourreaux qui s'échangent en quoi
une photo une photo à la télévision d'un
suspect il a des centaines d'amis des
victimes pour lesquelles souffrent eux
mangeable vient peut-être de leurs
ancêtres que signer pareil décret et du
curé une de leurs enfants
une source ne se retrouverait pas sur
bfm tv d'accord je pense que je le
rappelle le rapport c'est que quand même
une photo d'une personne qui a fait un
crime
moi je suis désolé il est suspecté oui
je sais mais à un moment donné faut
arrêter il ya des personnages a répondu
madame s'il vous plaît répondez juste
indiqué
ces bouquets quelques lauriers assassine
un policier s'est pas dissuasif excusez
moi un acte horrible c'est madame j'ai
une question à vous poser dans 48 heures
on le relâche parce que c'est pas lui
attendez il y a des preuves
non mais on n'est pas juste après le
même sens admettons admettons
présomption d'innocence ce n'est
peut-être pas lui pourquoi dans ce pays
on ne peut jamais rien faire masse qui
me ce qui me scandalise est installé on
ne peut jamais rien montré
on ne peut jamais rien dire merci j'ai
pas lu je suis désolé il un passif il a
un passif ne voit une un passif il a
commis des agressions
il était dans du trafic de drogue il un
passif il ya le policier qui vous dit
qu'il avait le coupable idéal
il a aimé nommer son ami ojani liesse
qui l'a confirmé je veux dire un moment
donné quand il ya des personnes qui sont
en danger pourquoi ne peut pas mettre
des inactifs mais attendraient leur
était de répondre non et d'un seul coup
j'ai réfléchi et je me suis dit merde et
moi je fais pas de théorie je ressens
simplement je me dis quand même
et effectivement le flic qui a vu la
mort de son copain tiré à bout portant
qui ne reconnaît formellement le jeune
homme et j'en suis triste pour lui a un
passé de délinquant lourd côté
stupéfiants il a fait des dizaines de
victimes en tant que leader donc là je
me suis dit hé merde
et merde oui on peut le montrer de quoi
là car là à ce moment là alors là oui
mais elle peut comprendre moi je peux
comprendre il a ajouté je ne sais pas
naître s'il vous plaît souplesse et pas
vis-à-vis de lui dire si ça c'est ça
martine salmon l'enquète ses collants
blancs telle occasion par ces pôles
enquête c'est ça le plus important
aujourd'hui bernard montiel la chaîne
rapport non non c'est pas bien de faire
ça c'est évident que c'est pas bien de
faire ça il faut imaginer aussi que ce
monsieur quoi qu'il ait fait et c'est
ignoble et c'est condamnable et il va
être que certainement condamné
on n'a pas à balancer le visage tant
qu'il n'est pas vraiment condamner là
c'est la justice médiatique c'est pas
bon on s'est alors dit je tiens à vous
dire que ce jeune homme quoi qu'il en
soit à une maman et un papa
non mais là le policier la cdc la
province été sacrée miss mais on
raisonne là en disant simplement il faut
le protéger ces droits sont diffusées
c'est que je suis et on sait très bien
que diffusé son image ça peut être pour
lui une promotion dans le monde de la
délinquance
elle va recevoir très probablement des
demandes en mariage en prison comme
salue ce magnifique non seulement ça n'a
l'air de rien mais c'est sûr même si ça
va contribuer à le glorifier ça va avoir
un effet pervers dont personne ne sait
combien coûte dg de l'aviation fait
tomber faut résumer aux yeux et je vous
dire on le montre voilà je suis un
enfant venait avec laurent seillier à la
raison et il faut arrêter de montrer à
un moment ça le starifie un chien pas si
je suis d'accord avec laurence la bbc
reconnue et référencée les policiers
n'aime pas qu'on montre les terroristes
mais ce que chez le ch et dans dans son
milieu de gens anti flics ça va être une
vedette est en prison a aussi pas s'en
empêcher le permettent arrêtez arrêtez
de faire nos vous êtes vous vivez gilles
verdez vous avez 40 ans de retard non
c'est vous et vous vous avez 40 ans tara
du tour au jour mais aujourd'hui vous
disiez ça gêne l'enquète ça ne gêne pas
du tout le trajet de l'enquêté aboutit
une chance sur d'avoir le gars après on
verra en il est innocent présumé
innocent ce cas là mais pas du nom s'est
passé
exemplaire de monter cette photo je
voudrais dire à benjamin que vous êtes
pour moi très en deçà de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui l'instantanéité de l'émotion
elle est là et valérie alatorre aussi
cette image là c'est toute l'émotion de
quelqu'un qui très vraisemblablement a
tué un policier et le voir le voir c'est
dire plus jamais ça
je le vis comme ça je ne lui pas du luxe
et le mi6 la manière des analyseurs je
les paie dj d'abord en mémoire et à
l'image la photo des lic masson o'shea
oui me souvenir de son visage à lui que
de connaître le visage du tueur présumé
où la vue sur le sol avec ce bagage et
préfère pardon et et il me semble que la
photo de ce garçon n'apporte rien fait
n'importe quoi a perdu à part de
voyeurisme il s'agit simplement d'une
enquête où il ya un garçon de 19 ans qui
est suspect d'avoir tué un policier
moi c'est tout ce dont j'ai besoin de
savoir ton visage je m'en fiche c'est
par ici simplement que ce type la haye
devant la justice et que la justice
fasse son travail l'a jamais deux choses
d'abord est-ce que vous parlez des
motions et nous sommes tous émus tous
émus par ce qui s'est passé cet atroce
le meurtre de ce policier cette atroce
est ce que la douleur de ses proches
est ce que la douleur collective que
nous ressentons est amoindrie par
l'exposition médiatique du visage d'un
suspect de son de son meurtre atroce
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas je sais
même que non et ensuite vous disiez la
vertu dissuasive mais quelqu'un qui
commet un acte aussi horrible n'aura pas
peur que son visage soit diffusée il le
fait déjà en ayant conscience que ce
qu'il fait malheur est bon
par exemple parce que ce raisonnement là
c'est le même raisonnement contenait ont
célébré il ya quelques jours le 10 mai
81 et l'abolition de la peine de mort
c'est ce qu'on dit on dise et abolir la
peine de mort vous allez voir ça va
augmenter les crimes de sang expliquent
les crimes de sang ou augmenter à cause
de l'abolition de la peine de mort non
donc ce que vous racontez sur les vertus
dissuasives là d'une publicité là d'une
sanction ultra répressive ça ne marche
pas tout cas à mon avis par contre deux
camps dans cette discussion il ya ceux
qui je le disais comme des vautours vont
faire un business répugnant sur les
mains vous fait sur la violence sur la
violence qui existe dans notre société
qui a toujours existé qui
malheureusement il sera toujours dans
nos sociétés et il ya ceux qui
lucidement essaye de répondre à cette
violence et donne notamment veulent
donner notamment à la justice a dit
henin à la police
la justice aux acteurs du droit les
moyens de l'empêcher d'abord que des
actes violents aient lieu mais ensuite
quand ils ont lieu de les sanctionner
comme ils doivent l'être parce que la
justice elle n'est pas rendue madame sur
les plateaux de télévision
ce n'est pas un sondage c'est pas un
vote sur elle est rendue au nom du
peuple français par des gens d'abord par
des par des cours d'assises alors des
jurés populaires par des magistrats airs
six mois ça le métier et qui savent le
droit plus que vous et moi
guillaume genton pour rebondir c'est ce
qu'a dit laurent ça fait des années
qu'on entend qu'on ne voit plus montré
les photos des coupables mais moi je les
vois toujours sur les chaînes d'info les
les photos des coupables sur quoi parce
que ça nourrit le voyeurisme des gens et
les gens aujourd'hui ces échanges même
sur what's app sur les messageries parce
qu'ils aiment bien voir ça mais moi je
les réussis
hier soir je les ai reçus mois sur
what's up cette photo mais ça ne serait
pas venu à l'idée de la diffuser parce
que je respecte ce policier sa famille
hier à l'égal de l'hommage national
non mais moi j'ai ça on met un nom sur
l'horreur vous allez me dire que pas une
seule fois quand il ya eu un attentat
qu'il y avait quelque chose vous n'avez
pas vu une photo en disant tu as vu la
tête du mec a fait sa famille l'a vu la
tête à elle n'a vu la tête 2-2 du
meurtrier celui de la russie à chaque
fin on peut pas faire les hypocrites en
disant aujourd'hui au nom plus jamais ça
je ne veux pas voir la tête de
l'assassin arrêté qu'elle arrose les
envoyer au moins une fois en disant
regardez la tête qu'il a regardé la tête
de l'horreur non en fait il s'agit
plaideuse mais c'est comme ça diffuser
la photo qu'on la personne aller
rechercher si ça peut aider
il cherche alors je suis bon pour et
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit oui à la
demande de la justice et à la demande
mais aussi rappelez-vous ce sur cet
attentat en seine saint denis
on avait eu il y avait eu ces jawad
était venu se pavaner qui s'était fait
arrêter en direct aussi sur bfm enfin
c'est un peu à double tranchant tout ça
c'est évident ça rien à voir la ccb oui
mais parfois bfm et ben hibon et puis on
a pu voir aussi des arrestations direct
sur bfm
mais après après c'est ça aussi la force
de bfm bruit sa voix la basse est
originaire de l'information directe
aujourd'hui on suit l'information en
direct ne vous en déplaise
on vit au rythme de l'enquète on vit au
rythme de l'arrestation on vit au rythme
de ce qui se passe et cette image là eh
bien on est dans l'enquêté
excusez moi mais c'est ce que les gens
veulent vivre lanka
des sensations ça n'apporte aucune
information n'a gardé que bfmtv at elle
bien fait de diffuser la photo du ce oui
à 43%
je vois pas où est la modernité parce
que jeter en pâture voit sa des suspects
alors avant c'était à l'écrit ça prenait
plus de temps sans doute mais jeter des
noms ou des images en pâture ça n'a rien
de moderne est en tout cas c'est pas la
société moderne dans laquelle je veux
vivre moi la société moderne dans
laquelle je veux vivre c'est une société
dans laquelle la police pétanque était
rapidement peu oui mais la justice elle
ne se rend pas sur twitter
heureusement justice parce que si la
justice se rendait là entre nous comme
ça au café du commerce même si ces
sympathiques d'être autour de cette
table et bien il y aurait beaucoup plus
d'erreurs judiciaires qu'il y en a
aujourd'hui il y aurait beaucoup
d'innocents condamné on a juste il avec
les exemples dans l'histoire montre que
le canton jettent à la vindicte des
individus quand on veut aller trop vite
on commet des erreurs
or la justice est une affaire sérieuse
la république est une affaire sérieuse
et un dernier mot vraiment les angles
moi ça me ferait sur le bouddhisme
c'était dans laquelle on rajoute la
tension la violence dans laquelle on
appelle à faire justice soi même parce
que c'est un peu ça qui est derrière
tout ça m'effraie parce que moi je ne
veux pas vivre dans une société comme ça
je lui donne une société de droit de
république et nous avons une
responsabilité médias responsables
politiques c'est aussi d'apaiser la
société pour permettre à chacun de vivre
sereinement en son sein